okay let's roll here mmm interesting
setup
what's unprotected nothing this night is
gonna have a rough day he's gonna be in
for a rough road ahead here this night
no problems mmm I'm thinking Knight f6
but might there be a reason behind
playing first f5 like a Dutch although I
have not had although I have not had
although I didn't have good success with
that the last time I played I dropped a
piece like in three moves four or five
moves anyhow things were bad my King had
a run for the hills like over here okay
let's regroup here d5 f5 Knight f6 c5
hmm actually this Knight isn't gonna be
too big of a problem it's good my night
out let's see what boy wants to do oh
now this I think c4 was the right idea
to me c5 to me the c5 move with d5 so
this is could turn out to be like well
I'm not quite sure it could just be
Sicilian there could be Queens game with
a lot decline type of thing a tirage we
might be seeing something like that
actually but there's something to be
said I think for this move right now
because guess what I'm ready to do this
should be 5 is a move that's available
giving a check and forcing the king I
think King site Castle is needed right
now otherwise Bishop check so let's see
how where my opponent is maybe c4 is
another idea
Knight here probably not a good idea
because of
obstructing this sea pond so I think
castle in fact on move to both of us
could have castled as soon as this night
is out
I could castle drop my King on my rook
if you're unfamiliar with this variant
of chess now this is probably not a good
idea so how to take advantage of that is
there even a way to do that I don't know
and here was my LightScribe bishop gonna
do it's kind of stupid bishop here night
here bishop here pawn takes can they
hang on to it maybe well pawn push it
might be something with that pawn push
pawn poised pod push chase the night
away expand on the Queen side I think
that works actually
now decision time do I play here or here
first earlier in the stream I was
emphasizing like crazy the idea of
retaining flexibility when there's prawn
tension maybe I should take my own
advice all right I'm gonna do that
d5 I could castle my pony can castle in
fact depending on the the setup you
start out with in Fisher random you
could castle on move one depending on
how the the king and rook are positioned
okay what about still this this seems
like very caveman like but I think
there's a purpose to it expand on the
Queen side I have my queen here
I have my rook here I have my bishops
guarding these squares I'm not really
thinking about castling there's no need
to do that right away and now that
there's pressure on this pawn I don't
want to do this because my rook is
unprotected if I do this takes I have to
capture away from the center what else I
think I like this one of the natural
type of reactions to upon push like here
with c4 is to break at the center at
this d5 point but there's not enough
support for that now one thing I guess
white could be looking into is try to
get a knight on b5 with a4 b4 Knight b5
but I doubt that that Knight can be
retained so now what
okay catching up with time they could
Castle I have a giant space advantage
and this is this is a problem and I
think the diagnosis here is getting all
the way back to the decision to play the
Knight to c3 this pod can't play that's
a problem the Queen doesn't have as much
scope for as long as this pawn is still
sitting there so now what pawn push I
still can't do anything with this rook
if I play here this drops this pawn push
here takes I can't even recapture take
here but we end up in a symmetrical
position I still a little bit of space
over here I'm dropping this pawn maybe I
think I want to keep these guys sitting
and get developed and how do I develop
maybe Knight here something to do with
that right here it could be difficult
piece to get rid of maybe I want to keep
them around and one of these two squares
to challenge on e5 or Queen here no
there's eventual of rook move after a
trade and queen is hit okay let's try
this actually Bishop here Knight d7 okay
let's get more development and he's my
bad Bishop anyhow okay that was a strong
Knight right here and my bishop needs to
get working I'm pointing right here
there might actually be a fishing pole
out of this setup you believe it the
Queen swing over laterally or not
let's get castled the pawn structure has
been a bit more clarified so I have a
better idea of what it is I want to do
as soon as this Bishop moves this Knight
is not protected there might be pawn
takes but then again after C takes B the
queen is watching over the knight notice
I'm keeping my opponent guessing here
let's get my rook here what am I gonna
do take maybe push push again that
actually is a possibility and that would
squash what let's play here I'm getting
ready for it takes in the night
recapture watch over this pawn takes
pawn is the threat if pawn takes now I
recapture with my queen and then not
only is the knight but also this pawn is
hit the knight is dead something's dead
I'm getting material lots of it and this
is a very committal move lots of
weaknesses are created because of this
h3 h4 f3 f4 and the seventh rank is more
vulnerable I get a rook here the King is
cut off from the action if we're
entering an endgame excuse me if we are
entering an endgame I don't know what to
suggest for white I started to move fast
I think they were trying to not lose on
time alright this is definitely
something you have to be concerned about
let's get my knight in there I guess
that part could be taken soon oh but
actually no I just push here I continue
going with my majority get my pawn up to
biess b b2 and that's gonna be TKO let's
take care and make sure of what watch
over this a little bit and I'm just
gonna get gone here even if it's
challenged I'm just gonna ignore it I
think
oh there's that move I'm gonna take this
because I'm pretty sure I can and rip
takes I just get these guys going here
they're very very strong bonds pigs
these pawns are pigs here broke up pawn
push is available and the rook is
actually trapped and get the other one
hang on no back rank mates my rook is
there to defend no back rank mates back
rank mates
looking for me on f2 the bishop moves
close to me stop the king move I could
have also picked up the bishop now
that's me okay
good game lots of fun I really do enjoy
the Fisher randoms let's see about
things here let's back up I would really
consider already at this point when I
play Knight f6 to treat it like a
regular chess position and consider this
c4 move to have a good response to c5 I
think d5 and then Knight c3 I mean the
Knights are still in their original
positions right being on the g g8 b8 g 1
b1 squares so consider c4 here I'm able
to strike at the center
I'm grabbing more control over the
center and this move is off you can't do
it
Queen pawn like opening do not obstruct
the C pawn I don't think that this
arrangement here is any exception to
that general rule you could be running
with so don't do Knight c3 instead what
can you do
you could play see for yourself that's
one thing
although there's a problem with that
isn't there if you do seafloor I could
capture and then your si pun is actually
in a pin mmm I wonder if this is
actually turning out to already be a bit
awkward for white as soon as I play c5 I
wonder what a computer would be saying
about this position right here what the
suggestion would be for white I would be
surprised if it would be suggesting c4
right here right now maybe this is a I
wouldn't say necessity but definitely
consider it C for having pawns side by
side in the center the ideal placement
is an e4 d4 structure but don't don't
undervalue a d4 in c4 structure either
both are quite good
again this being the ideal 1.e4 d4 but
also d4 see for having pawns side by
side my opponent is voicing that they
thought about the C pawn push but I
think at that point it wouldn't have
helped too much yeah yeah this this is
the point that it really wouldn't have
helped so if you're not able to get the
C pawn involved what are your
alternatives it's like okay maybe use
the C pawn to support your own center
but then this bishop has a problem right
he's not going to be too happy about
things so that's my early suggestion I
just have a ton of space right here and
maybe it's better that you actually keep
this night around somehow you do get the
bishop pair but I have a lot of
development here and get my Bishop out
get castled and things are real smooth
the space advantages is good in so many
instances maybe there's a try for takes
captures and then get this pawn going
but I'm not really seeing that actually
maybe right here is an opportunity to
take because I can't recapture like this
because of the bishop move here you're
getting some material
so I wonder if this is a better way to
put up some resistance be take C be take
C and then get your rook over here to be
honest I think I'll be able to end up
getting control over this and maybe even
subjecting this a3 pond to some pressure
right okay yeah it did turn out to be a
cramped position right here because of
the the queenside pond moves but anyhow
good game let's close out